do you think
we can fall in love i have arguments
about this all the time
uh do you think we can fall in love
based on words alone
well i think people have been doing it
for centuries
i mean it used to be the case that
people wrote letters to each other
um you know and then uh that was how
they
communicated and i guess that's how you
and dan go exactly
exactly exactly exactly yeah exactly
so is the answer a clear yes there
because i get a lot of pushback from
people often that you need
you need to touch in the smell
and you know the bodily stuff i think
the touch and the smell and the bodily
stuff helps
okay but i don't think it's necessary do
you think you can have a
lifelong monogamous relationship with
the ai system that only communicates
with you on text romantic relationship
well i suppose that's an empirical
question that hasn't been answered yet
but
so yeah i i guess what i would say is um
i don't think i could could any human
could the average human
could you know so so um if i
if i um i even i want to even
i want to even modify that out and say
i'm thinking now of um
tom hanks um and um the movie um
castaway yeah you know with wilson yeah
i think
if if that was if you had to make that
work
if you had to make that work with the
volleyball yet if you had to make it
work
could you you could you prediction and
simulation right so
if you had to make it work could you
make it work
using simulation and you know your past
experience could you make it work
could you make it work you as a human
could you could you
like could you have a could you have a
relationship literally with an inanimate
object
and have it sustain you in the way uh
that another
human could um your life would probably
be shorter
because you wouldn't actually derive the
body budgeting benefits
from right so um we've talked about uh
you know how um your brain
its most important job is to control
your body and you can
describe that as your brain running a
budget for your body
and um there are metaphorical
you know deposits and withdrawals into
your body budget
and you also make deposits and
withdrawals in other people's
body budgets figuratively speaking so
you wouldn't have that
particular benefit um uh
so your life would probably be shorter
but
i think it would be harder for some
people than for other people
yeah my intuition is that you can have a
deep fulfilling
relationship with a volleyball
i think i think a lot of the
the environments that set up i think
that's a really good example like the
constraints
of your particular environment define
the like
i believe like scarcity is a good
catalyst
for deep meaningful connection with
other humans and with inanimate objects
so the less you have the more fulfilling
those relationships are
and i would say a relationship with the
volleyball
the sex is not great but uh everything
else i feel like it could be a very
fulfilling
relationship which i don't know from an
engineering perspective what to do with
that
and just like you said it is an
empirical question but but there are
places to learn about that right so for
example
think about children and their blankets
right so there there's something tactile
and there's something olfactory
and it's very comforting i mean even for
even for non-human little animals right
like puppies and
so i don't know about cats but um but
cats are cold-hearted
there's no there's nothing going on
there i don't know there are some cats
that are very dog-like
i mean really so some cats identify as
dogs yes
i think that's true yeah they're they're
um species fluid
you